very often these problems Compound on
themselves Vladimir zielinski agreed
with everything you just said when he
said had
Joe Biden not taken the sanctions off of
Russia Russia would not have invaded had
Joe Biden not actually said if Russia
takes on a minor incursion into Ukraine
we won't do very much Russia very likely
would not have invaded so you see that
weakness from the previous
administration creating problems
for whoever the next but let's also
remember Russia never would have invaded
if we wouldn't have had the debacle in
Afghanistan right the idea that we left
Bagram Air Force Base in the middle of
the night without telling our allies who
stood shoulder to shoulder with us for
decades because we asked them to be
there think about what that told our
friends more importantly think about
what that told Putin and she right they
knew they'd never see another weak
president like this